okay welcome to the legends class thank
you thank you oh this isn't about me
today I want to talk about my favorite
player previous legends classes we
talked about semi Slav and we talked
about Bronstein and this class will be
Paul Morphy who is about a hundred years
before those guys and Paul Morphy is
obviously my favorite player everybody
knows that the greatest player who ever
lived Julian agrees and he dominated
like no other he beat everybody every
game so he was pretty good and against
the other top players of the day he
would score 75 to 90% and against weaker
players he would spot them a rook and
play blindfold and 100% this is pretty
good now there are detractors of Morphy
who say his opponents weren't very good
those detractors are correct and my
point of why he was so good was he
played well and they didn't so how did
he get good most people like Julian for
example he got good because he played
people who were better than them he went
AHA and then he played better and his
rating went up thirteen fourteen hundred
points ok Morphy you know played Rufus
of n doofus
those were his two main opponents and
then he got two very strong level where
he could play blindfolded and spot
pieces and seem eight and ten and his
opponents were like what's this piece
called so it's not clear how we got good
now there's many many many internet
pages about Morphy we could see here
born in 1837 if I remember correctly man
I'm going to get a lot of YouTube hate
if I'm wrong I believe that was the year
Michigan became a state I'm from
Michigan so ok and he died in 1884 now a
lot of a lot of people will dis Morphy
like people like Yassir Sara Juan who
say well more if he was good for three
years then he like quit chess so you
can't give him all the props he's like
if the guy was the best of the world for
20 or 30 years ok but
the guy's like I hate trance I'm not
playing anymore so how can you say he's
the greatest ever okay but I can I could
say whatever I want so okay so he died
pretty young uh he didn't really want to
be called the chess player he thought
that was like an insult
um but yeah he also got a law degree
while he was becoming the best player in
the world he went to Europe and he beat
all those guys and usually he was giving
a silent while you beat him so I don't
know some of his best games were
blindfold simultaneous games read see
hundreds of moves ahead thousands of
moves ahead even okay and and and when
brilliantly or three or four moves ahead
there was a planning Stanton who was
supposedly good if you look at his games
he wasn't that good and he would he was
always ducking Morphy more if he's like
Here I am and he would talk okay he's
like now okay and so they never played
because ridiculous now what to bed in
here okay so um one thing I do a lot of
research of my spare time I don't just
sleep all day so choked on my lies so
one thing I noticed was morphe and Stein
it's had a opponent in common than who
was that Lasker that was Grandmaster Ken
West can you believe it now what's that
correct right so I'm trying to figure
out who was better more for your science
as his science was terrible it was
worthy anyway yeah they had the same
opponent in common what was that guy's
name now you know tell me in the
comments on YouTube and Morphy score was
something like plus 18 that's good score
18 more wins than losses and signups had
a minus score against that guy so I was
like well okay we could see who was
better thinking it was burr but it
wasn't bird somebody better than bird
okay this will be better than bird
anyway very very long Wikipedia article
about everything because he had an
interesting life other than than playing
chassé and when he was a kid he was
really strong when he was 8 9 10 years
old and there's some funny stories here
on Wikipedia about you know people
getting mad because loser do 9 year olds
they didn't like that now they love it
yeah now when you lose a nine-year-old
you like yeah but back in the early
1800s here's the thing okay people think
they're good at poker and backgammon
because there's no rating system so
they're like I'm good
in chess they're like well you're 1200
there guys 2700 so you lose 100 games in
a row and they're like yeah okay well
back then they didn't have that so like
I'm good at chess I beat my friends then
if you lose to a nine-year-old who's
playing Bonnie fold they don't like that
they like wait a minute so actually the
Astra told me the same story about
himself when he was a kid he like beat
his friends so he's like I'm the best
I'd beat everybody I know and then he
turned on the TV
then he saw Bobby Fischer being
interviewed on The Tonight Show and they
were like World Chess Champion Bobby
Fischer he's like what he didn't beat me
it was this guy okay so ignorant is
bliss so they didn't know people didn't
know if they were good or bad at chess
so they all thought they were good and
then when they played Morphy they found
out that they weren't they're like wait
a minute this guy you know he like takes
his rook off plays vine fold makes fun
of me so they got mad some people didn't
want to play Morphy morpheus family was
actually quite good his uncle and maybe
his dad they were bad and and it's funny
even though the guy lived a long time
ago and he didn't play in these big
tournaments like we have now they played
in cafes or they played at which people
houses there's still this monster long
article with all kinds of pictures and
games and quotes and if you go to the
internet and type in Paul Morphy you
just see like many many many pages and
there's a couple of great books written
about Morphy also the pride in this hour
of chess man sounds tough world champion
he didn't to be called world champion he
was really mad he was like I'm not a
chess player okay crazy it's good to be
crazy though okay and then there he died
because you know that's what happens
when you're born in 1837 so tough yeah
now we're fine but then yeah and then
there's all kinds of nonsense written
about
because you know you're famous that's
what they do right right nonsense okay
like you know like Beyonce's a good
singer they're right nonsense when
you're famous right exactly yeah and
then they have even though it's
Wikipedia they still show some famous
stuff okay but I have more famous stuff
now this is the part I like okay
now you may like trash-talking as much
as I do like out it but here's some
results of matches he played okay so
like the first guy he played 50 games
and 145 now you don't see that like when
you know more is a [ __ ] play sheer off
it's not like 45 to 5 you know okay
then the next match 8 0 6 0 4 0 3 0 that
goes on forever and in preparing games
for this lecture I tried to show games
that you know you haven't seen a hundred
times and I just typed good Morphy and
then somebody won and the somebody was
always morphe I couldn't find a game
that he lost so I guess I didn't look
long enough
he has lost I know but I can't find
those games okay what's that right now
look at this results going down on your
screen it said plusses how many he won
and minuses how many he lost - 0 - 0 - 0
he did lose a game here that guy's
actually a famous player with a
Wikipedia article okay but mainly - zero
- zero - zero - zero now if I'm playing
Julian in a tournament his score is not
too good but if we're playing casual for
fun and I got Jimmy John's in one hand
and I got you know dominoes in the other
hand and I'm balancing Papa John's on my
head and I'm eating then Julian wins
half the games right like like couple
days ago okay if we play the tournament
and I'm not you know like on the phone
and holding ten pounds of food I'm just
checkmating and then I win now Morphy
most of his games were just like hey
let's play so he was in a cafe or he was
in a guy's house or he was on the street
somewhere he was at Starbucks okay and
so you see it says casual game casual
game and he never lost when I play
casual game on like I lost so what but
more feels like not a casual game now
we're serious right there wins every
game
so he's playing a match 23 wins one loss
right so pretty good you know I mean
like very reasonable 12 wins no losses
no draws and the guy has a Wikipedia
article bottom now one of my favorite
games which I'm not going to show
because I keep showing it in my lectures
is it gave me beat Napoleon Mirage and I
don't know who that is and I made a
YouTube video about it on my channel
last week and some guy put a comment
he's like that guy wrote chess books
that guy was a master I were an article
about that guy more if he was giving a
blindfold silo and beat him easily
so I'm like that guy's a master yeah ok
anyway I think he's a jack of all trades
master of none all right so let's look
at some of my favorite Morphy games
hopefully you don't know them now you
may think we're having technical
difficulties but for the first time ever
we're not right and the reason you think
we have difficulties is you may notice
there's a rook missing and when Morphy
played he was like dude you know this is
too easy let me take some pieces off
okay and then he would play and I know a
lot of Morphy games because you know
they're really great now if you watch
super GM's today they play too well
we don't want to learn from that ok then
nobody makes a mistake the game ends in
a draw or it's moved 38 and they have
one minute on their clock and they
blunder and then somebody wins ok now
more fees day he played well and his
opponents didn't if you want to see more
examples of that we'll go next door to
the Chess Club and I'll play blitz with
some people okay so but back then even
if more if he played the best players in
the world
they weren't anywhere near his level so
we saw a lot of beat downs and even
though I randomly picked wins that you
don't know they were still all less than
25 moves because he couldn't unless 25
moves that's ridiculous
ok so more if he's white and he plays
the scotch and he plays some kind of
gambit because that's how they roll back
then black played Shaq that's pretty
good and black white castle's so why
doesn't care about losing pawns
he's already ripped down white wants to
get
big attack okay and if he has a big
attack maybe he won't eat his rook for
the endgame so he definitely wants a
lead in development he wants blacks King
to be dangerous blacks like whatever
keep taking pawns don't develop pieces
to stay play pawn okay now more if he's
already threatening [ __ ] takes g7 so
Bishop f8 always play Bishop FA
although I think when black played
Bishop b4 check he wasn't planning on
playing Bishop f8 now vision of f8 silly
you don't you know he is setting up for
the next game but still okay II five now
Knight f6 is risky
so g6 rook e1 it looks like White's not
going to need this rook this game looks
like White's getting a big attack okay
and black took and white Turk and blacks
like yay I'll trade Queens I'm a rook up
solid okay that usually if you trade
Queens and you're up a rook you're the
favorite okay and more if he's like
check okay now black didn't defend
perfectly but more if he was spotting
him a rook
so if he defended perfectly that would
be a little unfair guys should make some
mistakes okay
so King e7 he's not worried about
discovered Shaq because he thinks Queen
takes rook will be checkmate but it's
double check right okay and now black
made a terrible blunder which is really
cool for our class okay black should
move his king out and allow rook takes
Queen Shaq and he probably would have
lost the ending a rook up because his
rook is hanging so white would have
gotten his rook back and with even
material this guy is not going to do
well against Morphy but he's like okay
free bishop and after rook takes Queen
he'll take the knight and he'll win but
instead white played Canwest keep going
keeps keep speaking continue your
thought Knight takes rook check
come on Ken check there you go now you
got it
check me yeah he's like wait a minute I
thought he was just kidding what that is
checkmate yeah you missed the bishop on
b2 yeah also so did black he was like
wait what yeah okay so that's a pretty
funny Morphy game cuz he won in like 12
13 moves by spotting the guy rook so
that's and he gave us clean away
he showed that guy okay for some reason
that guy's not the considered the
greatest player who ever lived
okay his opponent okay now more if he's
white again and for some reason he has
all of his pieces not good for his
opponent not good not a good sign okay
and more if he played Queen f6 by his
opponent right and this is supposed to
be a beginner class all right now the
beginners are happy okay so before
people played well they did not play
well then they said hey that's not good
then we stopped doing that
so Queen f6 if black won every game we'd
be playing Queen f6 today but since
black lost every game we didn't stop
doing that okay so 93 black stopped
Knight d5 white played in the center now
you guys like taking stuff this game
black took stuff and then made 800 Queen
moves in a row let's see how that worked
out black took we'll just Queen again
his Queens attacked you should move your
queen back to d8
then it won't get attacked every move
okay but this was 1800s give them a
break too actually Queen again yummy
yummy yummy tax the Queen again tax the
Queen again the guys get a good workout
okay
2x the Queen again tax the Queen again
always play the ship f1 tech okay tax
the Queen again and 94 didn't attack the
Queen descended his rook and wants to
play Knight d6 check with advantage okay
but blacks a pawn up so blacks probably
winning okay
age six attacking the rook why develop
pieces or playing the center when you
could move a pawn on the side now we're
talking that didn't work out well
okay Knight f5 or as I would say
julienne knife f5 and word I learned
there from you know remember in Soviet
Russia
it was so via Russia too from Vasily s
could throw Gnaeus in what country is he
from by me pronouncing his name now
Vasily s Catalonia's there's only one
country what now
what's the way you use the worst what
country would Vasily Asst could throw
Gnaeus be from with that kind of name in
Greece Greece man okay so he's Greek and
he was like knife f5 he must have saw
this game okay Queenie 696 check we got
another night to go to d6 with check
we're all set okay Bishop c4 c4 is
explosive as you know now if two
grandmasters were playing black would
super resign but then we won't have a
funny finish so that's good he didn't
resign people didn't resign back then
they got check created that's how they
rolled back then
Queen e7 and normally when you checkmate
somebody trading Queens isn't the first
thing you think of but this is morphe he
could calculate 100 moves ahead so he
was like okay this is this is the quick
way to win one legal move check one
legal move can west black has one legal
move now a5 is 85 is really illegal and
King a5 is also illegal yeah there's a
rook on G 5 don't miss him what's the
only legal move ken west
nope that's not a move resign you can't
find it he's like is this mate it's not
made ken west I wouldn't lie to you I'll
give you a hint pretend you're playing
the Sicilian what do you play I move one
there you go ok check one legal move you
already suggested it
ok now you may notice blacks King isn't
well placed I don't know if you notice
that no anybody and no you know the
right move
ok you ok c6 I missed that
okay but that blocks the night that's
ridiculous
okay now anybody who's a fan of MVL
which is all of you knows that he's
French and therefore what kind of moves
does he like to make not very good
another job that I'll make later okay
he likes to retreat like any Frenchman
okay
here we can we treat with initiative you
Rick g3 threatening rookie three check
yeah
and Ken West has many options ken was is
like I can stop rookie three mate no
problem now back in those days they
didn't develop all their pieces but they
did make a lot of King moves on the
other hand more if he developed all his
pieces so somehow you won every game
it's amazing
okay now resign back then so okay mate
and I was pretty awesome
but that wasn't fair because war if he
had all his pieces you can see how you
really needed that rook if he spotted
the guy at rook how could he have one
okay all right
right now more fee actually one with
black too I'm not kidding okay
now more if he did two things well he
would attack and checkmate you then when
you would play the King's gambit and
attack you would say thanks for the
pieces and you'd have nothing so okay so
he fled the French very common back then
no all right this is one of the biggest
beat downs I've ever seen white made no
errors and was destroyed in like fifteen
wounds couldn't make any legal moves and
I was like wait what usually they hang
all their pieces you'll be playing more
fee
okay so advance French f4 is a little
iffy wouldn't be played today by a
grandmaster people in the audience
relied come on f4 that's what I play
okay yeah ken was like f4 I learned a
new opening okay now f4 weakens a square
it weakens the square III III was
protected twice on move one by pawns
possibly three times if you're a
stickler now it's only protected once
but by no pawns let's see if more if he
takes advantage of that Queen b6
attacking d4 and then his Knights coming
in to attack d4
also the rooks coming Queen d3 not very
good this ship takes b4 check so
probably the guy wanted to move his
night because you want to move your
night but then this pawn is
insufficiently protected so he's like
all right queen d3 now when i move by
night I'm not blocking my queen
see now my Queens all hooked up and
morph he's like oh your Queens on d3
okay let's let's take advantage of that
notice how by feeing cuddling the bishop
and defending the d4 pawn he was no
longer defending III so now III would
have been strong
okay so blacks AXA piece I sort of like
blacks pieces sorta like all of them
okay let's when the Knights are good man
dish about g7 is good stops checks queen
b5 check trading Queens as you read d7
is great okay so a queen moved away more
if you played rook c2 can West is like
90 to check wins the exchange very
confused also a wins a rook because the
nine MP ones hanging but more fees like
now not rook see - okay now any
Grandmaster would resign but they don't
do that so queen d1 Grand Master Kan
west is like I'm excuse me the bishop on
b2 is hanging right you agree you agree
right it is hanging yeah but he played
93 yeah yeah so that was like one of the
more feasts on with all his pieces that
seems unfair right so that guy was good
although Julian's like come on that
guy's no good see yeah Julian's like
terrible and then in a very strange
event that usually doesn't happen in the
1800's white resigned yeah but man this
isn't so good yeah my this is a position
where the computer gives no evaluation
for plus it's too high as there's no
force to mate it's one of the few
positions that sneaks in there no
there's no number high enough so it just
like gives up I have to buy a new
computer now I'm sure it's some number
that doesn't exist
yeah that said like PI squared so that
you know 10 to the million okay so white
resign terrible okay
now
we're bees opponent here was just
terrible I search databases high and low
and you lost every game and and terrible
yeah that guy you needed like a no PR
guy and ends no good now easily lose it
every game look did he NN wow it's
pretty good
he played throughout the centuries ok
some people say NN means no name and
I'll let you guys decide ok now again we
are not having technical difficulties
white started without a rug
see there's no look in the corner ok but
morphe start without a rook me and you
weren't too good because you were too
good anyway so now you're really not so
good ok so more if he played the usual
you know sugar me do now when I teach
kids classes which I do often all the
kids raise their hand and say fried
liver fried liver time like this isn't a
restaurant anymore and I'm a vegetarian
so this kids got to go however we don't
see a lot of fried livers now because
you know terrible but the opening makes
no sense for either side they basically
black losses and white shouldn't play
the fried liver white should play d4
winning but alright but this is the 1850
so fried liver if a Grandmaster is white
in this position today with his rook on
a1 I hope that he would play d4 and then
start trash-talking because d4 is the
best move okay but Knight s7 the fried
liver if kids are watching they're like
fried liver and their parents are
feverishly cooking in the kitchen I
realized in there watching chess and
they're like here you go the kids like
what what's that ok I want the chess
opening all right so notice that white
is attacking the king and the knight
right and as out Melvina will tell you
that's called attacking the two pieces
your voice changed ok so it's all the
fork but blacks like no problem black
just blocks with the night oh the
computer won't let me because the night
is as Malvina will tell you what's that
thing called it's a pin so it's a fork
in a pin no wonder white one keep it
down back there
okay so black defended everything he's
the best King e6 now as well veena will
tell you when pieces are pinned you
don't take them you attack them again
right that's what you were going to say
so 9c3 attacking it again did black play
Knight takes c3 illegal right
so black defended his knight 97 I think
some people say night before is better
but you can't win the rook in the corner
so I don't know it's raised already down
there look the Morphy showed him okay
now more if he played castles because I
don't think blacks going to Castle okay
c6 defending the knight again D for
opening the center so if I was playing
Murphy and he spotted me a rook I'm
saying F I wouldn't have my King on e6
in the opening it would not happen no
opening what I have my King on e6 my
king would be so safe you'd be like why
did you give up three pawns and like as
my king is safe okay so the guy opened
up his King more cuz that's a pawn so
he's like wait I could open the e-file
and get mated yeah all right rook e1 run
away run away check check and you can
see this isn't working out too well for
black now if a computer was black it
probably could have defended better
probably okay that's why you spotting
the guy a truck okay Bishop d6 now
anybody in the beginners class named Ken
West can find the brilliant move morphe
played taking advantage of this pin that
bishop can't move you see Malvina bishop
can't move anywhere it's pinned so now
white played queen c5 very good okay now
King d7 is risky because Queen takes
bishop is made you agree right ken yeah
there's a rook on you one okay and the
only other legal move is there's one
other legal move you can be a yep I hate
when that happens
ken lessons like what happened how that
came in so fast
yeah well black got a prize for the most
King moves but they didn't know who to
give it to they're like who's that n
nobody raised their hand not me okay so
that was a nice boy he win as per usual
yeah this guy he played was pretty
suspicious this guy wasn't the best now
more if he spotted a knight now if I'm
spotting material I spot a rook because
my knights and bishops checkmate you
works are good in the endgame so
spotting a Knights harder in my opinion
than spotting a rook okay although more
if you made it look pretty easier as
opponent did all right F for the King's
gambit now again if your opponent's
spotting you a rook or a knight or a
queen you want the most boring position
ever and then you're up a queen and you
win but his opponents were like made it
really exciting and they made all
blunders so I was sort of funny okay
Kings gambit accepted g5 because you're
up a night supply the sharpest move
possible G for more fee sex another
piece he plays the Musial gambit without
his light on b1 sounds now he's down to
Knights okay Black has good development
as usual d5 that's actually not a bad
move takes c6 more fee sex a third piece
and as usual more fees opponents like to
run their King around because they're
like ham up a piece or two yay check
Bishop f4 so blacks winning because
blacks up three pieces on the other hand
black was winning when the game started
because he was up a piece and now his
King is a little iffy now he actually
has to play well that's not going to
happen what if these opponents aren't
going to play well okay this should be
seven not so good now the last thing you
want to do is open lines for your
opponent and not develop your pieces or
if your more fees opponent you could do
that so they're like wow a pawn Wow okay
blacks up three pieces so this one you
can be taking that pawn check and then
takes another pawn because that opens
more lines for white
okay so they didn't really know how to
play well back then or his opponents
didn't but when you're up to three four
pieces winning upon doesn't matter not
getting mated matters and opening up the
e-file just terrible Morphy was shocked
that he still had his rook on a1 he
didn't spot that he's like oh boy so he
played rook e1 I can't believe I have
that rook still okay here yeah now if
you're playing in the Chess Club here
and you're black you're going to win
because you're up three pieces but if
you're playing war fee he'll calculate
to me and you won't win so don't play
more fee I keep telling you not to them
but nobody listens okay and white played
rip takes East 7 just like you would
have because you would have not seen the
night on g8 so yeah
now Queen f7 is risky I'm serious okay
so he played King f8 after 9 take C 7 I
don't want to shock you too much but
White has made into and if you're taking
notes either at home or here made into
is good so if you have meetin to play it
now other than Julian let's let somebody
else the answer white checkmates into
the first move is check that helps you
also black did a good job here with
these pieces nice development Bishop e5
came to g8 and you'll tell me your mate
in one now no nothing I don't see a mate
is there a mate I mean there's a couple
of checks but they're not so good yeah
sort of like my checks no good
anyone this should be Bishop e5 was
close now that's not as close it's a
bishop check but not to e5
I can't believe Grand Master's of today
like Ken wasps aren't as good as
morphine I think it's what's in the
water you're missing this long
discussion here you really going to come
to class people at home you're missing
this you know it's a top-level
discussion just say just say that move
you don't have to know why he was like
Bishop h6 ridiculous he takes back his
answer that's correct
now there's two legal moves Ken West
Queen takes Bishop and King GA you agree
King GA you agree this is mate okay and
this is the move that's killing you're
like what wait I get Bishop boy now
meetin one Adams like all over that
Queen f7 mate so White's down seven
eight pieces that happens okay so
somehow that guy didn't allow that like
I didn't seem good enough to see any of
that did he see it because after nine
six rook I think White's lost if he
doesn't do that so he saw that he saw
Knight takes rook so yeah that guy's
pretty good
all right King f8 Bishop d6 discovered
check I hate when that happens
so what did he do can last what a black
he didn't resign what did he do he's in
check by the way yeah so what do you do
it was too tough
he doesn't have to he has a night on GA
he played Knight f6 and Julian's like
wait a minute I can beat that
yeah Rick f6 now Malvina she's like yeah
he called on me she's really happy I'm
attacking the king of the Queen what's
that called it's either a fork skewer a
pin right fork right he didn't want to
lose his queen
so he took and now ken west here's your
chance meeting one it's your chance oh
you want to you he can do it no no
anyone there you go yeah well yeah yeah
Queen e8 me yeah ma'am or if he was
lucky a lot when was it what you wanted
to do Queen f6 and then Queen f7 instead
of Queen e8 and then mate yeah yeah that
would be winning and n wins okay alright
now the last war fee game but not the
least was against the pitcher war all
way there's not a picture isn't there a
picture immoral he retired okay it was
okay I didn't make that up now again
we're not having technical difficulties
I see Ben Simon's messing with the
camera there is no night on b1 and it
was a simultaneous exhibition
so probably the Knights were missing
from every game maybe like the pieces
weren't all there they're like all right
off about unite we can't find one okay
so Kings gambit remember play as
complicated as possible you're up at
night that way you can lose quickly so
that's what they did the sharpest
possible line okay and now he could last
game he played Queen takes no he castles
okay Bishop h6 put it in H this ship
takes f7 check looks like the last game
this should take a queen check Bishop
takes f4 and these guys didn't defend
these positions very well when they were
getting mated so probably instead of
being two or three pieces up they could
have been one
he's up and had a safe King but they
like that two three B's double getting
mated that looks better on their you
know feels better okay
this should take except for Rick takes
f4 so blacks up a lot of material but as
Ken West will tell you white is
threatening meetin one what meat would
that be Ken right that's correct
Rick f7 me right and black is like not
I'm not doing that to me night age six
no Rick have seven for you and more if
he's like I have another rook really
usually he's spotting those rooks so I
will cast one okay so here black is
still okay but you know who's going to
defend this position you I don't think
so
you got a time machine I don't think so
maybe Stewie maybe because he could go
back there and take care of things
okay so Queen e8 do you think Morphy
traded Queens that's the way you made
them now played Queen h4 if you play
Queen g5 Shaq suggested by Ken West in
his head then queen g6 and even rex
could defend with black if only he was
here
alright so Queen h4 now this is a
typical Rex position white as a mating
attack but he's done a lot of pieces
okay sometimes it's either/or but here
it's both okay and black is like who my
kings in a lot of trouble he played d6
because the guys back then didn't
develop their pieces too often but he
was thinking about it he's like alright
d6 I'm going to develop a piece Queen f6
check King g8 queen takes h6 now he's
threatening rook f8 with advantage okay
black played a good move Bishop d7 and
he's got all these pieces defending
right now rook F a doesn't work let's
try it
Rick f8 takes takes takes now if it was
bughouse maybe white could you know get
start putting some pieces down there but
white only has a queen left and black
has two rooks a bishop and a knight
so that's the end of the attack so more
if you didn't do that he kept the attack
going now is this the position where he
missed a crazy mate I don't think this
is it now he played rook f3 what's his
next move ken worked to g3 and then
that's tough okay so 97 now he could
block with the night yeah and this is
where he missed them me no not yet okay
and he played h4 put it in H now one
thing morphe did was he attacked with
more pieces oh here he's out of pieces
so he's like I have an idea h4 h5 then
rook g3 okay so night g6 h5 Bishop to g4
very suspicious move H takes g6 dish
pawn takes now the idea is if you play
Bishop takes f3 who can find the winning
move for white who's not you know rate
of 2000 already saw the game who else or
if he's done a lot of pieces but he's
used to it he's not a lot of pieces a
lot
what's the winning move
ruk f7 Paulie doesn't lose but when
black takes and whites running out of
pieces that's the problem when you like
spot pieces and then sacrifice them you
need some more pieces what's that lose
for white or for black uh I don't know
maybe the ending is a draw maybe Queen
takes rook I take your bishop you'd
rather have black hey Kings open I might
draw what do you think racks how do you
win you can do it you could I would take
with the rook I guarantee it right but
then I'll take with the rook yeah yeah
then I don't know I'm defending but you
touch the right piece touch move g7 now
if it was White's turn to move you would
all blunder with Rick f8 which does not
win but Queen f6 incredibly wins
boy does Queen f6 win and then you're
threatening pawn takes rook equals
everything mate and you can't stop it
so if it was White's move this would
incredibly win because I'm going to take
on h8 with mate and you can't stop me
from doing it if you play Queen g6 to
stop Queen f6 not now this now this
works
yeah now we take a look or and a queen I
don't know it's your club Rex Rooker
Queen they both meet alright I'll take a
queen because that's cooler okay so that
didn't happen
instead he played pawn takes pawn and
I'm or feed plate it has a name but I
can't pronounce it the epaulette made
epilogue how do you pronounce that yeah
well you're the lowest rated player here
how do you know he played Rick f8 Shak
and the guys like thanks
and we played Rio cafe chat and the guys
like thanks and then mate yeah yeah that
was the close to save I got to be more
fee but it wasn't too close right sure
so more fee 1/2 those games by giving
them the sugar me do the other half he
would spot pieces sacrifice more pieces
you notice not only did more fee attack
the king
they hardly ever put him in Shack more
fees King was it in check too often
there was the one game when they forced
King h1 they showed him then okay
otherwise their King is running around
every game and he's using all of his
pieces what I like about this game was
more if he played h4 h5 H take g6
threatening g7 so he did bring extra
attackers into the game even though they
weren't pieces so now you can see why
he's so well known not only did he win
but I never get to win like that when I
went I'm a pawn up and the guys like guy
he's a tempo ahead you know where are my
Knights trapped on c5 I didn't see this
check right but when he won like it was
made Sakka queen may sakit rook may
there was every game like I couldn't
find again we didn't sack everything
with me I was like I never get to do
that I get to lose like that but I never
get to win like that so well that's for
my favorite player Paul Morphy those are
some of his nicest wins there's some
nice books about him obviously the
Internet has a lot of information and
hopefully one day you know we have time
machines and we can make great matchups
like Murphy and McVeigh of now there is
a matchup right back backed up yeah well
let the way format go via to turn 10 but
okay so yeah I was asked to do a legends
lecture by Marco Vega but since he
hasn't turned 10 yet I'm going to wait
maybe when he's 12
okay so if you're watching this several
years from now you'd be like yeah Marco
videos good what do they mean yeah but
he's eight or nine now so we don't know
he's good yet don't tell anybody
all right this has been fine go that the
Chess Club and scholastic center of st.
Louis with our legends lecture and
please don't clap just throw money and
see you next time it's good they didn't
clap they listened